[Music]
an inglorious basterds Quentin Tarantino
wrote a funny sequence where a German
officer mixes up the story of King Kong
with the story of the American slave
trade every question he asks has the
same answer for both after shift sighs I
love you thank you yeah
as you know merely cotton competition
kittens are childish did ya finish
Teague she stood as niggas in America
right that's what King Kong's oh ah the
German officer and intern Tarantino
clearly think King Kong is an allegory
for the slave trade yet the creators of
King Kong have repeatedly denied this
interpretation of the movie saying there
are no hidden meanings it's just a story
to them this disconnect between creator
and audience brings to light one of the
most important questions in film
discussion is an interpretation still
valid if it's not what the artist
intended the answer has broad
implications for analyzing art if
meaning is objective then discussion
becomes much more narrow critics must
take the artists word as law and only
look for meetings that the artist
consciously intended on the other hand
if meaning is subjective a critic can
find any message they want in a film and
that means anybody can throw around any
theory they want English teachers can
overanalyze curtains no matter what the
artist says so where is the line let's
have a look at how artists talk about
and make their movies to figure out the
best mindset towards analyzing into over
analyzing film some directors do clearly
state their intentions for a movie in a
rare interview from the Coen brothers
they mentioned that The Big Lebowski is
based on noir detective novels from the
30s and 40s but with a humorous twist it
has the main character in over his head
a complicated and morally ambiguous
narrative and an unreliable supporting
cast but instead of smoking cigarettes
like most noir heroes he smokes
marijuana one of the several humorous
twists on the conventional detective
stereotypes for deeper movie ideas many
directors create a movie with an idea in
mind but not only will directors hide
the meaning of their movies they may
even film the movie deceptively in
American Psycho director mary harron had
William Dafoe portrayed his character in
three different ways the first way the
characters thinks Patrick Bateman killed
Paul Allen I just wanted to know if you
know
the second he thinks he didn't do it
people just disappear and the third he's
unsure to think that one of his friends
killed him for no reason whatsoever
would be too ridiculous
isn't that right Patrick Harran edited
these poor trails together to have the
character constantly switch his opinion
of Bateman between takes the choice
creates a movie full of uncertainty and
it adds to the frenzy toxic male
dominance within the movie angly used
the exact same technique in Brokeback
Mountain I played it as though I knew
what was going on with Jake's character
Jack and that he had been cheating on me
with men and I knew about the gay
bashing and I also played it as though I
had no idea that this is how my husband
died and those takes got merged in the
final film so I don't actually know Aang
knows the truth in his head and it's not
important to me because I think the
ambiguity is what is the strength of
that scene and what's heartbreaking
about it when filmmakers create a movie
with multiple meanings they tend to keep
their intent a secret I'm not gonna say
what it is oh you may not I never talk
about themes it's a very big shame when
something is finished and then people
want you to translate it back into words
it never will work it never will go back
into words and be what the film is it's
like describing a piece of music you
don't hear the music you just hear that
see the words it's better to let people
conjure up their own ideas having seen
and experience the film I mean they want
you to say I think you know this is a
story of the duality of man of the
duplicity of governments something like
that and you know I hear people try to
do it sometimes it usually is bullshit
or if the work is good it's it's sort of
Kubrick might be the best director to
look at when discussing overanalyzing
because his movies are some of the most
analyzed in American cinema
the documentary room 237 focuses
entirely on fan theories about the
shining some of the ideas suggested in
the documentary are pretty ridiculous
like when they claim Kubrick airbrushed
his own face into the clouds as the
family drives to the hotel after hearing
about his intense shooting schedules and
extremely detailed production design
fans have seemed to build a mythos
around Kubrick believing
put specific meaning into every little
thing despite all of the sort of
apocryphal stories about me almost all
of which are untrue you don't have
unlimited resources and they do watch
the budget and you know you do have to
account for what you're doing the
stories about cubic largely ignore how
he himself described his shooting
process he says he actually doesn't
always put a particular meaning in his
directing choices I'm pretty good at
generalized statements when I'm asked
what is this but I still can't tell
somebody what has the glory is about I
find it's much more of an intuitive
process more like what I would imagine
writing music is like rather than a sort
of structuring an argument this
intuitive approach doesn't make
Kubrick's films any less meaningful
it just means while he's making the
movie his intent isn't always
immediately obvious to him he instead
makes choices that feel right instead of
constantly dealing with hidden meanings
I never deal with subtext when I'm
writing ever ever ever I keep it about
the text I keep it about the scenario
because I know there's a lot there but I
don't want to I don't want to know it
right now so where does that leave room
for analysis in both cases where
directors hide the meaning and where
they don't work with a specific meaning
in mind the viewer can't know the
objective truth but that doesn't mean
analysis is hopeless the very basic
things especially from where mr. orange
is coming from I'm dying and I want to
go to the hospital but just in writing
those words just all this stuff just
started pouring out and that was when I
realized it was a father/son story going
on and in this interview Tarantino
reveals a crucial truth about filmmaking
he shows us how he subconsciously put a
deeper meaning in his movie it doesn't
matter if directors work with one
meaning in mind or work purely on
intuition everybody brings their prior
experiences with them in the creative
choices they make and that doesn't stop
at the director every person involved in
the process of filmmaking places their
worldview into the work and a good
analysis reveals these hidden meanings
to me it's very obvious I mean of course
King Kong is a metaphor for the slave
trade I'm not saying the makers of King
Kong meant it to be that way but that's
what that's the movie that they made
whether they mention make it or not this
analysis works because it fits with the
time period the movie was made it's not
only convincing but the analysis also
makes the movie more impactful some
interpretations seem to miss that
analysis should add something meaningful
to the movie in this particular
interpretation King Kong shows how white
people of the 1930s may have feared the
free black
elysion in America not only is that
interpretation well supported but it
also invites the viewer to think about
the movie in a fresh and interesting way
even if it is true that Kubrick
airbrushed his face into the clouds how
does that add to the movie and strangely
enough maybe some stories are better
enjoyed without analysis Kubrick once
said if you submit to a completely
logical and detailed analysis of a
supernatural movie it will eventually
appear absurd the true measure of a
great supernatural thriller he says
isn't in it's hidden meaning but in if
the audience had a good fright believed
the film they were watching and retained
some sense of it with Brokeback Mountain
the true analysis of Jack's death isn't
what matters the fact that Angley leaves
the audience uncertain of Jack's fate
makes his ending that much more
heartbreaking there's no sense of
closure for us or for Ennis so maybe the
next time you watch the ending of 2001 a
Space Odyssey don't obsess over the
details
Kubrick actually did reveal what he was
going for in that I'll link his
interpretation in the description but
before you click on that watch the
ending one more time and think about the
emotion it evokes because even with a
particular meaning in mind he
brick-built that ending based not around
his own meaning but around how he wanted
it to make you feel so when your teacher
over analyzes blue curtains in a story
the problem isn't that it's not what the
artist meant the problem may be that the
teacher got so caught up in analysis
that they missed what made the book so
great in the first place
[Music]
a big problem with overanalyzing film
comes from under researching if an
analysis is inconsistent with the rest
of the movie or doesn't have a lot of
concrete evidence it doesn't hold up
well in most areas of film criticism
education is key to coming up with the
best analysis when it comes to actual
film production the same principles
apply to learn more about filming
professional footage with tools you
already own you can sign up for the DIY
filming class on Skillshare Skillshare
has over 20,000 classes that cover tons
of topics from business to filmmaking
the first 500 people to click on the
link in the description below can get
two months of completely free access to
Skillshare that's the filmmaking class
plus thousands of others ranging from
creative writing marketing and design
thanks for watching and thanks to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video